i think there's a shift i think
someone's going to change check us out
so we got the story from
nbc 10 philadelphia in a convenient
store
chain first pennsylvania's sheets
i'm saying that very carefully for
youtube to start accepting crypto
we're very excited to be working with
flexa to roll out support for
cryptocurrencies
and other types of digital assets at our
stores linda smith payments manager for
sheets set gonna be very careful with
that we're probably getting demonetized
anyway they're gonna be like
you can't say those words so anyway they
announced that they're going to be
taking uh what is it
uh bitcoin dogecoin uh uh ethereum
litecoin and other crypto con uh
currencies this is a major chain i mean
you've you've had cheats before right
yeah i love sheets you do that was like
my high school
it's like wawa versus sheets college
stop stop at place
after like rehearsal it's pretty good
yeah and they got good it was it was
groundbreaking when you could go in you
have a machine and you could pick like i
want a sausage sandwich with
onions and this and then it's made to
order first gas station i've ever seen
that at
least more than just addiction i'm a
penn state alumni and the
current ceo she's from the area family
and everything so she
talked to like some of the business
entrepreneurship classes uh
who do you think their biggest
competitor is sheets yeah
i gotta get creative here so it's not a
it's not a gas station it's the region
so i have no idea i don't know
it's mcdonald's wow what and like we all
think gas but you knew it right away
that it's not gas
all their margins are in food they
completely view it to be a competitive
service to mcdonald's and that's who
they're always focusing on gas is a good
idea it's like if i gotta stop for gas
and i'm hungry
it's like oh that one's got a gas pump
the other one doesn't i guess there's
some places on the road when you're like
driving a road trip you'll see a
mcdonald's with gas pumps
but it'll be like am pm gas pumps with
mcdonald's attached to something yeah
exactly so this is this is big i look at
what's going on with the stocks and i
wonder if it's all still part of the
plan
you know a bunch of people get these
these stemi checks they throw them in
stocks
and then everyone rallies and everyone's
cheering for it and then i wonder if the
big move is to get
cryptocurrency new technology new
opportunity certainly a lot of people
became rich off dogecoin
and certainly a lot of people lost a lot
of money on dogecoin because it's a game
of hot potato i guess
if you didn't sell your dogecoin you
didn't lose anything but some people
panicked and sold and they ended up
losing everything
so i wonder if there's going to be a big
shift and
you know with these with more and more
corporations adopting crypto uh what is
it i think kfc announced they were doing
dogecoin as well
yeah because it's good marketing yeah
and doge might actually be a good crypto
cash
it is a low cost easy to transact coin
it takes a little energy
it doesn't matter uh if it's
inflationary because you're doing quick
transactions with it you don't store
your value in it you store value in
bitcoin
so it's actually might actually be
pretty good ian's got this look on his
face
such trash dude such it's such
filamental trash it's like you can make
as much of it as you want
and it has 10 000 per day i think if
that's hopefully they're going to keep
making that much but there's going to be
like what is it a trillion
30 trillion of them or 48 but think
about think about this
you have your money stored your your
value stored in bitcoin
and you're like i'm going to go to the
store today so you pull up your phone
you swipe and say
transfer bitcoin to doge and then you
scan your thing boop and you transfer
the dose that's the future of economics
you have some doge for quick cash and
most of the value stored in bitcoin
and like i think a company should be
able to say if you pay us with doge
we'll give you 10 percent off if you
pass with ethereum we'll give you seven
percent off if you pass it so then it's
up to you
as a consumer to pick the currency that
they want you to use
and they probably are holding a bunch of
that currency so it increases the value
of the currency when you buy it
and i mean this healthy market it's not
the first time we've heard a big
business gonna
you know adopting crypto but i do think
it's big because it's a gas station
and there's incentive now for people to
have more you know what's really
fascinating is i used to do videos on
bitcoin
and they would just tank nobody cared
yeah you know so a few years ago i was
uh
2018 i'm like man these bitcoin prices
are are crazy
and it would get like 40 percent of my
average view count it's like really low
but if it was an important story i'd
covered anyone say well you know i could
talk about this
now it's like we had uh big bitcoin
stories and i'm like definitely going to
talk about this and some of my most
viewed videos like the interest is
absolutely off the charts for regular
people
looking into crypto i i would love
for us to be off fiat and in crypto
100 i'm interested how we're going to
replicate cash
because i like cash coin like will it
just be doge cash yes it'll have like a
little rfid chip on the
phil no you have your phone but then
it's if the power goes out you're in
trouble that's the i want to
find the uh
if there's a solar flare i know
obviously i'm going i'm going out on the
line here
hold on theoretically you could like
enter your passphrase
right into any terminal right and access
your doge account
i don't want to put a microchip under my
skin no you don't have to like it's
it's that 10 word phrase right imagine
if you walked up to a kiosk you never
needed a card again
you just went you know dog car elephant
banana ship and then boop there's
something about having the in your hand
and it's like this is
the thing that you want it's not in my
mind it's not in
some database yeah like i can hand it to
you and you can hand me the thing
maybe that's gonna be considered old
school because like you can rob it and
like
you can't rob an idea necessarily i
think i think we're seeing a great reset
brother
oh that's for sure yeah so are you from
the great reset
oh i thought you meant more of like a
higher meta level just like
we're hitting some sort what do you mean
specifically so there's a there's the
world economic
forum the navas group they've proposed
something called the great reset which
they just refer to as a reset of global
capitalism
so you look at what's going on with the
chaos in the stock market the chaos and
the crypto markets the chaos and the
dollar
the mass printing of money the
quantitative easing the economic
shutdown
now the meat shortages the gas shortages
and
what's happening is that i think the
dollar is going to
you know crap out and i think
if you can't buy a burger the barbecue
shop down the street put up a sign
saying we don't sell brisket
it's too it's too expensive so it's not
worth it for us i'm like you can't get
brisket at a barbecue shop what are you
doing
you know so they do have it now but it
flickered and out
okay now we're here there's gonna be
more meat shortages chicken shortages
if you can't get it what good is your
money right
gas shortages can't go driving there's
no gas i'm not gonna go wait in line
when those huge lines right out of those
gas stations because the colonial
pipeline hack
how many people probably said you know
what i think i'll go for a walk today
huh
you know what's really crazy you know
what's becoming extremely popular right
now
rollerblading because of mayweather
no because bars were shut down
restaurants were shut down and the
repeated sentiment across the board from
people is
i had nothing to do and i was bored so i
went in my closet and grabbed my old
rollerblades
no joke so now it's becoming really
popular rollerblades in the u.s are like
sold out across the board
wow oh yeah this is crazy
roller skating too so like women seem to
be
roller skating for the most part and men
are rollerblading but
this is a profound change in human
desire
all of a sudden there's like videos like
40 you know 40 and 45 year old dudes
being like i'm gonna go rollerblade
because they've got something to do
finally but you don't need money for
that
then you get some guy who's a dogecoin
millionaire and what does he do he's
like i don't got anything to do with it
so he buys a lambo i guess and then
puts the money back in doge and just
sits on it it's interesting to see what
people revert to so in 2008 2009 most
stocks took like
did horribly but uh tobacco alcohol
actually continued to rise
and this in this last run in 2020
home depot and lowe's killed it like we
have not everyone's doing
diy projects at home they're like i'm
i'll do this it's that garage project
yeah it's just something to do and their
online sales they
destroyed it and then what happened
lumber and steel
cross costs are through the roof and now
people can't get it lumber's insanely
i'm not uh too familiar with steel oh
actually no yes xlx is a stock that it's
the
u.s steel or whatever uh going down or
up up
up um and didn't lumber just hit a new
high it's been ripping i don't know if
it's a new all-time high so that's
relating to home costs going on so look
at look at what's happening
what did the climate change people say
you got to stop eating red meat
i've heard this since i was a little kid
all my vegetarian vegan friends like
it's really bad for the environment
what does greta tunberg say how dare you
we must get our fossil fuels tomorrow
not 2013 not 2025 tomorrow
what gets hacked oil meat wow
what skyrockets and costs so people
can't buy it lumber
steel yep so what do people do they go
outside and go for walks and they go
roller skating
they're doing things that don't cost
them money meanwhile
other people who are like buying fake
money are millionaires
like the whole system is out of whack
yeah it's just the other it's a great
reset
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you